[Music]
these days you've probably seen me in
the tabloids for a lot of other things
Teen Mom star Farrah Abraham back in the
headlines this time for an arrest at the
Beverly Hills Hotel the Beverly Hills
Police Department tells et they arrested
Abraham on charges of misdemeanor
battery and trespassing we are told
Abraham was asked to leave by a hotel
security officer after a verbal
altercation with hotel guests around
1:00 in the morning
the officer reported that Abraham struck
him in the face when he tried to prevent
her from re-entering the hotel the
police tell ET Abraham showed signs of
intoxication at the scene and the 27
year-old was booked at the Beverly Hills
Jail where her bail was set at $500 the
starlet was released midday Wednesday
dressed in the hotel's iconic banana
leaf print and a rep for ferret lzt
quote this situation has been blown out
of proportion
farah has not been charged and was
released this afternoon a
misunderstanding occurred and there was
no battery or trespassing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]